thanks a lot for the introduction
um in this work we're going to show you
that garbage circuits are not always the
best choice if you want to have
efficient secure computation maybe it
might pay off to you to combine
different protocols together and that's
what this work is about it's joined
worked with daniel dimler and michael
soner and was published at ndss this
year
so we're going to talk about secure
two-party computation in the semi-honest
model throughout this talk
and the malicious case is completely
open we are only talking about simeonist
secure two-party computation as we all
know has
many privacy-preserving applications
going all the way back from private set
intersection over auctions biometric
identification machine learning whatever
you can think of there have been
proposals for doing it securely in the
secure two-party setting
so let's step back one step
and look what an application developer
would need to do to actually get a
secure two-party computation protocol so
he has an application in mind and knows
the function to compute securely
first he chooses one representation of
this function either arithmetic circuits
or boolean circuits over and whatever
then expresses this function as this
representation and then we have many
protocols available arithmetic circuits
for example you can do with additive
homomorphic encryption like dtk or payee
or for boolean circuits you have yaw as
one choice but you also have gmw or many
other protocols
and finally you need to care take care
of all the recent optimizations as mike
summarized nicely in his talk like for
yao we have point and permute freaks or
fixed key goblin
half gates um actually we didn't
consider half gates yet because our work
was
previous to half gates and it would be
interesting um to see how half gates
come in as well
so the motivating example let's look at
computing the minimum euclidean distance
which is used commonly in biometric
matching applications for example for
face recognition or fingerprint
recognition there the server holds a
database s1 up to sn of biometric traces
and the client inputs are query c
and they want to check if the c is in in
this database
so what they want to compute is a
minimum or euclidean distance so first
compute the euclidean distance between c
and each of these elements in the
database and then finally compute the
minimum
and if you look at this
function we want to compute securely
this is very nicely represented as an
arithmetic circuit it's additions and
multiplication so we would favor these
protocols here
but the minimum is lots of comparisons
and multiplexing and bit operations so
this is nicely done in a boolean circuit
and what's left is we would like to now
first compute this as an arithmetic
circuit then switch over to a boolean
circuit and then finally um compute the
minimum with the boolean circuit
that's all what mixed protocols are
about
maybe
the issue that some functionalities are
particularly expensive in one
representation if you look at addition a
boolean circuit to add two numbers of l
bits has all of l gates whereas in an
arithmetic circuit it's just one
addition gate
even worse for multiplication you have a
quadratic number of um gates in the
boolean circuit versus one simple
multiplication gate in the
arithmetic circuit
so in previous work um
where we proposed this tasty framework
which allowed to combine pie yeah
encryption for arithmetic circuits and
yao for boolean circuits and for payee
essentially one party holds a public key
a
pk and the other party holds encryptions
under this public key and then you can
easily add under additive homomorphic
encryption if you want to multiply you
do a one-round protocol um to get
multiplications
so big drawback of of these protocols is
that these multiplications and
conversions
previously used expensive public key
operations you need to decrypt at some
point and if you use public key encrypt
encryption this is really expensive and
in fact we showed in some previous work
with florian cashbomb and axel
schweitzer
that
due to these high costs of public key
encryption yao is often much more
efficient than um
so the goal in this work is can we get
rid of public key encryption at all
and um precompute all the crypto as much
as we can
so the road map of what i'm going to
show you next
and our contributions is first i'll show
you that ot based multiplication is much
much faster than public key base of
multiplication
then second we propose a framework
called aby which allows to combine all
these protocols together and mix them
in different manners
and we can efficiently convert between
these different protocol types using ot
only
so
for ot bass multiplication we use a
multiplication protocol proposed by
gilboa in 99
and it goes as follows so
assume we want to compute the product of
two three bit values x and y
so if we look at school book
multiplication we need to multiply x by
the bit zero y zero
we need to add two x times y one plus
four x times y two and that's
actually what the protocol does
is the sender chooses a random value r0
from set 2 to the 6 because we have 6
bit outputs
and inputs into ot the value are 0 and
r0 plus this value x
the receiver inputs the bit y0 and
obtains the string s0 which is r0 plus x
times y0
and they do that for the remaining bits
as well except that here e inputs are 1
plus 2x and here are 2 plus 4x and
here the receiver inputs the bits of y
so finally
the sender sums up all these ri values
and takes the inverse of it and the
receiver sums up all these si values and
what we see here is that if we add these
shares
that's exactly the product so given
three ots
we have multiplied and have a shared
representation of the product in the
variant
so now what's left is we just
instantiate ot efficiently using ot
extension which is based on the
symmetric precrypter only
based on a protocol by isha at all and
some recent optimizations
we showed at ccs 2013.
so these are the benchmarks now
run on a lan and a one um scenario
if you look at the communication the
green one is using payee multiplication
the red one is using dungard geisler
crogard multiplication and this blue one
is ot based
communic
the ot based protocol and we here nicely
see
that this one has quadratic overhead in
terms of communication but if you look
at the run times we are about two orders
of magnitude faster than using public
key crypto based protocols
so this aby framework now allows to
combine
different types of sharing arithmetic
sharing where we do multiplications
using this ot based protocol i just
showed you we have boolean sharing where
we use the gmw protocol and we also have
yao's garbage circuit and we have
efficient conversions to convert freely
between these different representations
and then we implemented all these
protocols using state-of-the-art
optimizations we batch pre-compute all
the crypto operations as much as we can
in this work we use strong assumptions
for maximum efficiency um as you just
showed maybe um
it would be worse considering also
weaker assumptions and paying some price
and efficiency but we wanted to go as
fast as possible in in terms of
efficiency
here and finally we use fixed kas to
benefit from the a's and i instruction
set
so
what's this arithmetic sharing
it represents a value of v as the sum of
a share a and a share b party a holds
share small a party b holds share b and
they are just mod 2 to the l where you
this l is some some integer like 64
bits
so
this arithmetic sharing allows free
addition by just locally adding the
shares and it also allows cheap
multiplications which is just one
message in the protocol and this
arithmetic sharing is a good choice when
you have multiplications
the next type of sharing is boolean
sharing which looks similar except that
now we
do a bit wise sharing of a and b
and
we compute with the gmw protocol here
and so we have free source by storing
the shares locally we have one message
per and gate and this is particularly
good for multiplexing because we can do
there are protocols using just two ots
for a multiplexer whereas a circuit has
ofl
um and gates
and finally we have yao's garbage
circuits where one party holds two keys
k0 and k1 and the other party holds as a
sharing the key corresponding to this
value that is secret shared
and for yahoo's garbage circuits we have
weak source and no interaction per end
gate because we can pre-compute all the
garbage circuits and send them later on
um
so
this is a zero-round protocol
and yao's garbage circuits are actually
quite good for comparisons
so we implemented a couple of operations
and one very interesting
outcome was the following
if you want to multiply
two values in a yau sharing if we use it
use a garbed circuit
we came to 1.1 milliseconds amortized
runtime 100 kilobytes of communication
and zero message zero messages in the
protocol
but what now if we convert from yao to
arithmetic sharing then do the
multiplication here where it is much
cheaper and then convert the result back
to yao sharing and we saw that the
runtime was improved by a factor of 10
and the communication even by a factor
20.
i'm confused how can you have 100
kilobyte communication when there are
zero messages
and we pre-compute all all the
communication all the communication we
center the garbage circuit
it's the online time only ahead of time
you communicate one kilobyte and dealing
exactly
um that's ahead of ahead of time
and the serum messages are
in the online phase we don't need to
communicate
so that was one interesting observation
so now let's look at the different
conversions so if we have an application
the inputs are first plain text then we
convert these plain text into one
sharing for example arithmetic sharing
then do some multiplications here
convert with this a to y to a yahoo
sharing do some comparisons there and
move all over here and finally
the result will convert back to a plain
text and um this is the outcome of the
computation
so um this conversion is free converging
from a yahoo share to a boolean share
costs nothing because we just take these
permutation bits which might call these
colors of of the yao keys and this is
directly a boolean sharing
inverting from a boolean sharing to a
yao sharing
it's just one ot we input the boolean
sharing into the ot and then get the our
shares so this is also quite cheap
converging from an arithmetic sharing to
a yaw sharing we just first convert the
arithmetic shares into yao
representation and then we evaluate an
addition circuit within yao so
that's this conversion and from boolean
to arithmetic sharing it's a protocol
which is very similar to the
multiplication protocol using ot which i
previously showed you
so that's a summary of all the different
types of conversions we have and you see
here the com the computation in number
of symmetric key operations goes down up
to 12 times the bit length of of
the representation the communication
goes up to 6 6 l times copper where
copper is the security parameter and the
number of messages is also quite low and
for these three types of
conversions we use ot
so you see these
conversions are actually quite cheap in
terms of computation and also
communication and add only a few number
of messages
so now given this aby framework we
looked at different applications and one
is the minimum euclidean distance which
i showed you in the beginning
and these are now um the type of sharing
we use for computing the distance and
the type of sharing for computing the
minimum and we see combining arithmetic
sharing and yaw sharing here has the
lowest runtime which is by factor 10
faster than
than using boolean sharing only
also in the wide area network setting
measured between two amazon clouds
located at the us east coast in japan
we get
a dramatically faster runtime also in
this wide array network the
communication is best for arithmetic
sharing and boolean sharing
and the messages only obviously
uh the number of messages is best for
your sharing so you can trade off
kind of the the messages versus runtime
versus communication depending on the
actual scenario you're looking at
another application is private set
intersection
where we used a set intersection circuit
proposed by huang evens and cuts
which first sorts the inputs then
compares these sorted inputs and finally
shuffles the outputs and looking at this
shuffle part of the circuit this part
contains many multiplexers and these
multiplexers benefit from this boolean
sharing because we can do ot for
multiplexers
and these are
the performance results
we see it's a bit faster here to use
boolean sharing only in the land setting
whereas yao plus plus boolean is the
fastest in the one setting
and the communication is best for
boolean sharing and here again yao
sharing only has the lowest message
complexity
so to sum up this aby framework allows
mixed protocol secure computations of
different sharing representations we
abstracted this framework from the
underlying details of the secure
computation protocol so the programmer
only
converts between plain text and these
different sharings and says well
multiply add whatever operations and
doesn't need to
know the underlying details of the
crypto protocols we use only fast
symmetric key crypto throughout all the
protocols and make our code available
it's on github under this url
for future work
we'd like to look at using this
framework for further applications
we finally like to
automatically sign these assign these
operations to the sharing times
currently the programmer has to say i
want to do a multiplication convert to
arithmetic
representation multiply and so on we
like to do this compiler assistant and
finally a big open question is can we
extend this to stronger adversary models
like combining speeds with tiny ot or
whatever protocols are around for the
malicious setting um how expensive are
they the
conversion costs in the malicious
setting if they are not too high there
might be hope to get hybrids of these
protocols as well
and with that i'd like to thank you and
look forward to your questions
so this second direction that you put
for future work about automatic thing i
don't know if you try but it looks uh
you know given the stable you know
exactly the time you know to go from one
sharing to another and so on
um
how complicated do you think it looks
like even like you without thinking you
would do like a dramatic improve i mean
you can do something automatic uh
you know
did you even try um so we tried um
you you can formalize the data as an
integer linear program and then solve
this interdiction linear program to to
automatically do that we looked at that
for only for this payee and yao hybrids
but it's it's doable it's a it's an
optimization problem essentially if you
have all the runtimes but these are also
the runtimes i showed you where average
over multiplayer execution so um the
actual runtimes might might be a bit
different from the ones i i showed you
a soluble variant or it's something that
you will have to approximate because
usually it's empty complete to solve
this integer or you think for this size
i guess we threw it into a
solver and and um for small problems we
looked at it but not for large
functionalities
you just have the functionality you want
to compute and you can automatically
assign which parts you need to be or you
have some specific primitives that you
know are good in each of these
representations and you optimize based
on those
like comparison is good and good
so this could be her heuristics um like
if whenever you see a comparison you
could heuristically do a yao sharing and
then and do it but essentially you need
to assign for each type of for each
variable you have you have to assign
with sharing type it is
and then you you can associate
the costs and this is can we represent
this as an integer linear program and
then
for instance the aes circuit i mean
would that be something that uses a
conversion
really complicated
so we looked at several hundred
instructions only
um
at
much much smaller circuits we didn't
look at large-scale circuits like as yet
so one thing that i want to say is
probably the wrong one to use for
additive neuromorphic encryption
lattice-based cryptosystem in most
circumstances i believe would give you
better performance of course there's a
lot more work in implementing here than
there is implementing lattice-based
cryptosystem so there is some learning
curve that need to be done but it's i
mean it's synthetically certainly better
and probably better in practice as well
uh in addition you have the advantage
that you can enlarge your parameter and
get quadratic morphism and higher degree
which could be helpful depending on the
so this is another area to explore when
you install different types of
that's interesting we looked only at
this dgk optimization to compute mod n
instead of mod n squared of pi e but um
that's really an interesting direction
to follow
the times you gave were they
assuming that all the pre-conversation
has been done already
sorry um i gave the total times in in
the final diagrams heading both
so
is there a way to schedule this i mean
what what does the software do if it is
running out
so far we analyzed the program and
determine how much precomputation we
need and we pre-compute everything for
one single program but it would be
interesting to interleave this
pre-computation phase with the online
phase in an actual system
we didn't look at that yet
um just a quick question uh you have the
table that some of the conversions uses
oblivious transfers and some do not um
can you just quickly give me an idea of
which ones add round complexity and
which ones do not
um
like in the conversions yeah
right
um so for example uh this um
this um from plain text to boolean
sharing there you just send um you send
a share over so it's just elbits of
communication in one message and for
these ones uh you need two
messages because you you need ot for
example converting a plain text value to
a yaw share
if the
if it's for party b you need to run ot
there
and that's where this message complexity
comes from
one more round yes exactly
so the starting point currently is a
sequence of operations so you have you
have conversion operations to convert
between them and then you have a
multiplication operations on these
sharing types essentially
and
we are we're hoping to find compiler
assistant um
to find this automatically essentially
giving in a high-level description of
the program
so
first let's thank the speaker